the leonardo da vinci codex hammer
5500 to start 55 5.5 million dollars to
start it
good start 5.5 million dollars to start
so it's 1994 and we're listening to an
auction in a sales room at christie's in
manhattan still with me then five
million five hundred thousand five
million eight hundred thousand five
million eight hundred thousand six
million dollars thank you six million
five hundred thousand seven million
on sale is a one-of-a-kind leonardo da
vinci manuscript known as the codex
hammer
at 16 million 17 million on the last
telephone 18 million
at 18 million in this room
19 million on the telephone now the
audience in the room doesn't know this
but a representative for microsoft
co-founder bill gates is bidding on the
phone
19 million 500 000 i'll be happy to take
gates is up against a group from a bank
in milan that's sitting in the front of
the christie's sales room 25 million
26 million the bidding is heating up 27
million 28 million at 28 million dollars
it's away from the room now and on the
telephone at 28 million dollars at 28
million dollars it's on the last
telephone at 28 million dollars
i'll give everyone time it's with you at
28 million dollars any more
28 million dollars then
in this room in on the telephone rather
at 28 million dollars
on the telephone in this room at 28
million dollars but in the end 28
million the manuscript goes to gates
thank you
i'm michaela tandera and this is
priceless
in this episode we're taking you inside
the world of rare books manuscripts and
old masters works to tell you about how
we've estimated the value of one very
special notebook with ties to the
world's most expensive painting ever
sold at auction
the salvatore mundi
for this notebook we considered values
ranging from 50 million dollars all the
way up to 4 billion
and we're going to show you how we
narrowed that range to settle on one
number
joining me for this is chase peterson
withhorn and editor on the forbes wealth
team
hi chase thanks for joining me hi
miquela thanks for having me
so back in november 1994
microsoft co-founder bill gates was 39
years old and pretty much at the top of
his game
he had just gotten married to melinda
gates on new year's day of that year and
was in the middle of building his
multi-million dollar mega mansion xanadu
2.0
he was described in our forbes 400 issue
of the magazine that year as both a hard
worker
and brutally
candid yeah you
may be the richest man in america or at
least the second richest man in america
well that's simply based on taking the
stock i own in microsoft and and doing
some type of multiplication and in fact
that fall he had just appeared atop our
forbes 400 ranking of the richest
americans with an estimated net worth of
9.35 billion dollars right and then amid
all of this he buys this one of a kind
leonardo da vinci manuscript at a
christie's auction for 28 million
dollars
yeah and gates loves books we reported
that same year that gates envied his
friend warren buffett because he had
more time to spend reading than gates
did so gates sort of went out and bought
the ultimate book with closing fees from
the auction house it came out to 30.8
million dollars
i'm looking through a copy of what's now
called the codex lester which i
purchased online for about thirty
dollars
when bill gates bought the manuscript
rather than naming it the codex gates
after himself
he decided to rename it the codex lester
after an earlier owner
and flipping through this copy i have to
say i can't read a word of this
that's because da vinci wrote it
backwards which is what he did for much
of what he wrote
it's not exactly known why he did that
but some have said that's because he was
left-handed and he didn't want his ink
to smear
but one key difference between my
version and the one bill gates owns is
that while my version is bound in the
middle like any typical hardcover book
every page of the original codex luster
is held in glass to make it easier to
view all the pages
so it doesn't really look like a
notebook anymore
so of course da vinci never called it
the codex lester or the codex hammer to
him it was just his collection of
scientific observations and
illustrations and writings mostly
focused on the study of water
it is believed to have been compiled
between 1506 and 1510
in fact it was also noted in the codex's
1994 auction catalog written by late da
vinci scholar carlo pedretti that the
mona lisa is quote indeed a visual
synthesis of leonardo's scientific
knowledge as summed up in the codex
while dozens of manuscripts like the
codex have managed to survive the
centuries intact the codex lester is the
only da vinci notebook that is still in
private hands the rest are owned by
museums around the world inside besides
da vinci's writings there are also about
360 drawings and diagrams throughout the
manuscript
according to the christie's auction
catalog for the 1994 sale the codex was
described as being in good and stable
condition
500 years later the codex is in such
good condition in part because it hasn't
changed hands many times
according to the provenance in the
auction catalog a few italian artists
owned the codex after da vinci's death
including a painter named giuseppe getzi
who apparently sold it in 1717 to thomas
cook a man who eventually became
england's earl of lester
it stayed with the earl of leicester's
estate until 1980 when it finally went
up for auction
oil tycoon armand hammer bought it that
year and 14 years later gate spotted at
another auction
art is one of the toughest things we
value for our list because the value is
just so subjective and you really don't
know what something will sell for until
it hits the auction block
so how much is the codex worth today
if all we do is adjust the 30.8 million
dollars that gates paid for it for
inflation that gets us to somewhere
around 50 million dollars today
so i think we could legitimately set the
floor at that price
it's worth at least what gates paid for
it
but we need a lot more information than
that before we make our estimate and so
the first place we looked were the
auction records for the codex from the
1980 and the 1994 sales
back in 1980 according to an associated
press report the man who was the earl of
leicester at the time decided to sell
the codex which had been part of the
earl's estate for more than 250 years he
needed to do that because in order to
pay the inheritance taxes on a previous
earl of leicester who died in 1976 they
needed to sell off some stuff
so they decided to hold an auction
through christie's and it took place in
london in december 1980. the person who
ended up winning the auction was armand
hammer the 82 year old multi-millionaire
chairman of oil and gas giant occidental
petroleum months earlier he had appeared
on the cover of forbes and he was a
member of our very first forbes 400
ranking in 1982 he appeared on our list
with an estimated net worth of 150
million dollars
i guess i'm wearing a great many hats
one of my hats i wear
i'm a capitalist
hammer is also the great grandfather of
hollywood actor army hammer another hat
is my hobby for collecting art
and my enjoyment owning these work of
wonderful works of art
and seeing these works enjoyed by people
all over the world
people who
often would never get a chance to visit
the great museums of the world
armin placed the winning bid and paid
about 5.6 million dollars for the codex
which was less than the roughly 10
million that it was reported experts
thought it might sell for
the italian government had reportedly
been expected to participate in the
auction but just weeks before the
auction happened a devastating
earthquake struck italy and the
government ended up skipping the sale
still it was a record-breaking event
a new york times story on the sale
remarked that it was the highest price
ever paid at auction for a manuscript
and to put into perspective how much
less art sold for 40 years ago
the sale of the codex was the fifth
highest price for any piece of art sold
at auction ever after the auction he
told the press i'm very happy with the
price i expected to pay much more i
think it's the greatest acquisition i
ever made i'm going to show it all over
the world
there was a bit of an odd snag with the
purchase and forbes reported on it in
1994. apparently hammer had made a habit
of buying things with occidental
petroleum money that included footing
the bill for not only the codex he
purchased for the 5 million in 1980 but
also the tens of millions of dollars
spent creating his own art museum in los
angeles while hammer was alive we
reported that oxy shareholders sued
three times asking to be reimbursed for
what hammers spent on art and the museum
our 1994 story said hammer was a master
at litigation and the aggrieved
shareholders had to settle to keep
building costs at 60 million dollars
hammer somehow convinced the courts he
was increasing shareholder value however
weeks after the grand opening of his
museum where he planned to showcase the
codex and other art he had collected
over the years hammer died at the age of
92. after his death hammers estate
became tied up in a series of new
lawsuits that began with the niece of
hammer's late wife suing for a piece of
his art collection and other assets amid
all of that the codex went back to
christie's in 1994 where it was once
again expected to bring 10 million
dollars this time though it sold for
three times that in the battle we heard
about at the beginning of the episode
between gates and the italian bank
okay so to recap
when it sold in 1980
it was expected to sell for 10 million
dollars but ended up going for half that
when it sold in 1994
it was also expected to sell for 10
million dollars but ended up selling for
three times that
so
what do we do with any of that and how
does that help us come up with a number
for today
exactly that's why these valuations can
be so tricky in cases like these that's
why we have to turn to the experts who
know more about this than us that's
right so
first we looked to experts in the world
of rare books and manuscripts to learn
about the qualities that make a book
valuable
there are all sorts of factors that come
into play
condition
provenance there's also something called
primacy
which is being the first something like
the first printing in north america or
the first time a new word was used in
print and then there's also rarity or
how rare this exact copy or version of a
book or manuscript is
once we've decided that the book is
worth looking at for its condition
for its provenance
the first question we're asking but
we're going to ask it again is what are
we actually looking at if it's a first
edition of moby dick
that's a great thing to have that's
darren winston he's the head of the
books maps and manuscripts department at
freeman's auction house in philadelphia
freeman's was founded in 1805 and is
actually america's oldest auction house
earlier this summer very fittingly as
the country's oldest auction house they
sold a copy of the declaration of
independence for 4.4 million dollars so
once we've deduced that at the first
edition because it meets all of this
criteria then we look at the condition
and we base the condition on what's in
our hand and how you look at a book
that's 150 170 years old
it then becomes
a first edition of moby dick and we can
go into the auction record and look at
previous copies of that exact same book
when it sold where it sold what its
estimate was what it brought
but admittedly darren told us that he
wasn't a da vinci or codex expert and
was hesitant to put a value on it out of
the gate
so next we decided to try some sources
who not only know old masters works but
they know da vinci really well
my name is robert simon i'm
an art dealer in new york i work as well
as an art appraiser and my background is
as an art historian robert simon is
perhaps best known in the art world for
having a very close connection to a
painting that is synonymous with money
power and controversy
the salvatore mundi
for those who don't know it it's a
painting of christ that sold at a
christie's auction in 2017 for
450 million dollars
which is by far the most expensive work
of art that's ever sold at auction
christie's billed the painting as an
original work by leonardo da vinci
himself however
other critics have disagreed with the
truth of that claim
simon's connection to the painting is
that back in 2005 he and a colleague
actually sort of rediscovered the
painting which was in terrible condition
they bought it from an auction in
louisiana for just over
thousand dollars
simon has said that it took a couple of
years after they bought the painting to
become convinced himself that he was
dealing with an original work by
leonardo
given simon's connections to the
salvatore mundi and his experience
running a gallery of old masters works
he seemed like an excellent source to
speak with for this valuation but as it
turned out he also had his own personal
connection to the codex
that's right in 1993 simon was hired by
the trustees of the arm and hammer
museum to do an appraisal of the codex
back when it was known as the codex
hammer
this is the clipping that i had taken
out of the new york times in 1980
when it was to be auctioned when armand
hammer bought it so you know i it's
something i've sort of been following
for you know a good part of my life
simon shared with us his own process for
how he estimated the fair market value
and the appraisal he put together nearly
30 years ago like we did earlier in this
episode he considered the price that it
sold for in 1980 he also pulled together
a list of artwork that he found it to be
similar to
my feeling was that the codex was quite
a bit more valuable than any single
drawing would be
so that was kind of the basic first
principle what by leonardo can we
compare it with and then how do we
rationalize the difference in the kind
of object it is then
i went to those other items that were of
kind of the same
[Music]
rarity in as works of of the renaissance
that had been on the market in his
appraisal simon selected five comparable
works all from the renaissance era two
were da vinci drawings of draperies both
sold at sotheby's in monaco on the same
date in 1989 one sold for nearly six
million dollars and the other for 5.2
million dollars
simon also included another work by
davinci
a sheet of studies including sketches of
a child embracing a lamb
that sold for 3.6 million dollars at
sotheby's in new york in 1986.
he also considered a painting done by
renaissance artist puntormo which was
purchased by the jay paul getty museum
for 35.2 million dollars at christie's
in 1989.
and the fifth was a drawing by
michelangelo called the holy family with
the infant saint john the baptist which
also sold to the getty museum in 1993
for 6.3 million dollars
these went into the mix
and
trying to balance them and of course one
of the things in doing an appraisal like
this is you just
don't put them in a mix whatever but one
tries to lay out in a rational
way
why one is
has a higher value than the other why
one is or a lesser uh
market appeal and then try from that to
come up with a single value
and one of the other one of the
principles
of and the differences between say an
auction estimate and
an appraisal and this is for what we
call fair market value appraisal is that
we come up with a single value
understanding that
it's very rare that we kind of hit the
bull's-eye but that that is um that is
the opinion of the appraiser and that's
that was the process and that's
um it was a challenge and uh it was it
was a
you know a thrilling uh
project to be involved with
ultimately in his appraisal which simon
submitted in december 1993
he decided that the codex's fair market
value was 50 million dollars
so in discussing what the codex might be
worth today
robert simon brought up a recent sale of
a da vinci which was of a teeny tiny
three inch by three inch drawing of a
bear's head which sold in july of this
year for 12 million dollars
that estimate sort of got you thinking
in another direction though right chase
yeah when i heard about that 12 million
dollar sale i remembered that the codex
had about 360 illustrations inside of it
so i thought what if gates cut up all
the drawings into individual little
works of art and sold them off that way
if one drawing sold for 12 million
dollars that would mean that he could
sell off this whole book clip to pieces
and earn something like four billion
dollars
it's a truly horrific prospect but there
would there are people in the world that
would probably uh do that whoever cut it
up would be pilloried forever
slicing up and selling off a beautiful
manuscript or book is not without
precedent though robert explained to us
and if you look at the
illuminated manuscripts that are from
you know missiles and you know
these are renaissance manuscripts many
of them have been broken apart simon
talked about how there have been a
certain subset of book dealers called
breakers who made it their job to buy
books and then tear them apart selling
their illustrated pages piece by piece
what it does is make you
realize how important
the fact that the codex has survived
intact
is and so i think it's you know not so
much
let's look at it and see what would
happen if we took scissors to it and
divided it up but just to say
here we have such something of such
significance partly because it has
survived 500 years
without you know being uh being
destroyed so hypothetically though simon
explained that our logic of taking one
drawing and reviewing the sale price of
that to extrapolate what a whole
manuscript filled with drawings might be
worth was something he considered in his
own appraisal however we should probably
note that it seems unlikely that as the
owner of the codex gates would actually
do this
he's gone to extra lengths to make this
work as a whole more accessible to the
public taking
leonardo's notebooks and
translating them so everybody can
understand the way that davinci thought
a little better than before is very
important that's gates talking for a
video posted on his blog a few years ago
around the time that he exhibited the
codex lester in some museums in europe
he created something he called the
codascope which was software built to
help museumgoers actually read da
vinci's backwards scroll so here you're
just seeing the page
exactly
as it looked to davinci this is the
mirror where we flip it around and now
here it is in english okay so our four
billion dollar estimate isn't all that
realistic
but if our maximum value isn't four
billion dollars then what is it
well
as we mentioned the most expensive
painting ever sold at auction was the
salvatore mundi for 450 million dollars
we asked robert if the codex if it went
up for sale again
could it compete with the mundy's price
uh he spent
much more time as a writer scientist
draftsman than he did as a painter and
so you've got
the painting itself is you know much
more
a rare object
robert pointed out one other unique
distinction the codex is something that
for most of the year let's say you have
to keep it under lock and key and out of
the light you can't really
show it off whether it's to your you
know best friends or in a museum if
you're a public institution the salvator
mundi can be exhibited and
if it goes to a museum in saudi arabia
and people travel there and go to see it
i mean it would have in terms of its
that income value i was talking about
would have you know a phenomenal uh one
you know perhaps quite in excess of the
450 million dollars that it brought at
auction
so i thought this was super fascinating
that you could actually consider a work
of art as something that could not only
hold value and appreciate in value but
could also be a business generating
income for its owner over time so
keeping all of those things in mind and
knowing what he does about the codex
today
robert simon told us that he thought it
would not sell for less than 150 million
dollars
so it's difficult to get much better
than someone who has actually appraised
an item
but we ended up contacting others who we
thought might know the work well too
we should note here that we did reach
out to christie's as well as bill gates
to ask if they had any comments on the
value of the codex today and if gates
himself had the codex appraised since he
bought it but christie's declined to
comment and a spokesperson for gates
never responded to our questions
so we reached out to martin kemp who is
another da vinci scholar and an oxford
university emeritus professor
he told us via email that his guess
would be quote over 100 million dollars
we also spoke with stephen massey who we
heard at the beginning of this episode
he was the auctioneer at the 1994
christie's sale he said that he would
guess that if the codex were to go up
for auction again
the auction estimate for the item might
be 150 million dollars
everyone spoke with the caveat that we
could never really know what the codex
is worth unless it actually goes up for
auction
in the end we decided to take the
average of all the recommendations we
got from our expert sources everyone
agreed like robert simon said that were
it to go up for auction today it would
not draw more than the salvatore monday
which sold for 450 million dollars but
no one thought it was still worth the
30.8 million dollars gates paid for it
that average of every expert opinion
worked out to about 130 million dollars
and that's the number we're using to
value it this means the codex is
certainly one of the world's most
valuable pieces of art
but it makes up only about 0.1 percent
of gates 134 billion dollar fortune
which we estimated for the forbes 400
this year
according to a cnbc report the median
net worth of someone who is 66 years old
which is gates's age is about 266 000
so
gates buying leonardo da vinci's
notebook is the equivalent of a typical
66 year old splurging on
a new ipad
billionaires just live in a different
world
thanks for listening to priceless this
episode was reported by michaela tandera
produced by michaela tandera and
jonathan palmer with additional research
by sue radlar
[Music]
you